If your app let's people buy things,
it must also let them ask for a refund.
Your app has to have the code for
processing refunds.
Sending a refund hit to analytics
does not execute the refund.
It simply reports it.
You can read about sending refund
hits in the developer guide.
You can report either a partial or
a full refund.
When you send the hit for a refund,
you must provide a transaction ID.
See here it says in the Developer Guide,
the matching transaction is not found,
the refund will not be processed.
Your app must keep track of
the transaction IDs for itself.
Analytics isn't going to do that for
you.
So it's important to note that Analytics
has a six month limit for refunds.
So that doesn't mean that your app can't
issue refunds after six months, but
refund hits to analytics won't take
affect after six months of
the original transaction.
If you're up for the challenge, go ahead
and add a refund button to your app.
I leave it to you to do.